are you doing today sir i'm good by the
way
how did you steal my best friend robbie
thompson's office that i want to know
i do not know this is a matte painting
so maybe robbie gave this i'm joking
it's you know clearly it's it's it's
uncanny anyway i i already love you go
ahead
that's a great way to start i'm going to
start let me say on on my side uh how
great of a job you did with this
material i'm assuming it's literally a
love fest as everyone's coming in saying
this must be a very hard day to do press
uh it's been honestly very lovely i'll
tell you this uh the truth is like
i've been in a cave making this movie a
long time you know i mean it's because
of the pandemic there hasn't been you
don't go to the the screenings you don't
you don't mix you don't go to the
previews it's been a very isolated
experience and today has just been
lovely everyone's reactions like oh
it feels wonderful quite frankly i'm so
glad i love this show so much and i
wanted the film to to be worthy of it
and and it feels like people are
agreeing that we did a good job and that
makes me so happy i can't even tell you
i'm gonna say great job instead of good
but moving on um so the thing about this
is you need to make sure with the
editing and the way you're telling the
story that the audience never loses
empathy for evan can you sort of talk
about uh making sure that the audience
doesn't lose empathy for evan while
you're watching
well that yes
that was a very early thing that was
very important to me and stephen
levinson did a wonderful job of adapting
his own book with a screenplay and
making certain decisions that that i
just would always lean into
the need for in a way the need for the
lie or lean into the
the emotional undercurrent of what was
going on and how
this very very strange thing was like a
win-win for everybody
until it wasn't and then once it wasn't
he had to come clean but more than
anything else i really just focused on
the kid this is a lonely
father's gone
like he has depression he has anxiety
his mother works all the time he's alone
in that house
constantly he's alone all summer and
like how do you not have empathy for a
kid like that you know he he does a
terrible thing he makes a terrible
mistake and he sees it through but like
i never lost i never lost my sympathy or
empathy for him uh it helps to have ben
platt uh perform the role god knows but
really in the it's
it's conception uh empathy is what i led
with
uh i am always obsessed when i talk to
filmmakers about the editing process and
i always ask like how long was their
first cut compared to the finished film
especially for fans of this material who
i'm sure want to see everything you shot
sure um there would say i'd say at the
end of the day 20 believe it or not 20
minutes was cut out between the first
cut and the final
and literally only one scene well two
scenes were lost one was something it's
like the fans wouldn't even know about
because it wasn't in the stage show
something we explored another thing like
a cafeteria scene that we ended up not
needing so basically
really the the lifts came from inside of
material and taking out pauses and this
that and the other and just kind of
constructing it that way but no i mean
what you see is what you get you know
there there's no
extended cut there's no plans for it
it's like
we we delivered like ultimately what the
movie was supposed to be
yeah it's basically i i gotta go but
it's basically you just took the air out
of the scenes that had too much air
basically yeah it's like if you say it
in three lines but you you when you shot
it you set an eight oh let's say it in
three and let's see how that feels no
you didn't always do it but you did it a
lot so yeah that was it just trying to
really just move it along for sure
i already got to go um next time i talk
to you i'll ask you about a thousand
other questions i i would love that
anytime you want to do a follow-up i
appreciate it